starting around let's say about 1790 or
60 90 or so you know so for about 80
years before the founding America and
Great Britain had a very uneasy
relationship essentially you had the
Americans trying to govern themselves
through their elected legislatures but
constantly running into difficulties
with the governors of the colonies who
were usually appointed by the king yet
royal governors elected legislatures the
arrangement as I say was uneasy but it
more or less functioned
each side was willing and when the
crunch King was able to get along with
the other what changed though was the
French and Indian War England conquered
France and that meant the end of any
significant military threat to the
colonies from then on that led to two
things first of all it meant that the
colonists were no longer so concerned
about the protection offered by British
arms and what it meant for the British
was we no longer have to coddle these
guys they'll come we you know they'll we
can make them pay their share of the of
what it takes to govern the Empire so
we'll start putting taxes on them and
we'll start restraining their local
Liberty now that's what the British
we're doing and on the other side the
Americans were saying that's not going
to happen because we don't need you guys
and that's what created the basis of the
clash
you